chantal julie du philippe pascal
monseigneur du pays mesdames messieurs
les premiers ministres madame lapointe
chat collègues parlementaires élus
municipaux
messieurs les représentants des
premières nations mesdames messieurs des
représentants étrangers distincts et des
invités comme beaucoup de québécois
c'est avec beaucoup de tristesse que
j'ai appris le décès de bernard landry
je lui avais parlé quelques jours plus
tôt et on s'était promis de se voir dans
les prochains jours monsieur landry
m'avait dit qu'il voulait m'aider à
renter au match malgré nos différends
ça montre la hauteur et le sens du
devoir de cet homme d'exception
aujourd'hui on est tous réunis pour
saluer le départ d'un grand patriote
pour utiliser un mot qu'il aime et m
danone en demie a été un grand serviteur
de l'état mais surtout un grand
serviteur de la nation québécoise cette
nation son peuple
il l'a aimée de toutes ses forces il l'a
défendu avec fougue avec passion avec
panache
jusqu'à son dernier souffle bernard
landry s'est investie dans la vie dans
la vie politique et publique pour voir
le québec s'épanouir pour voir le québec
prendre sa place dans le monde sur
landry et mais se dire avant tout un
militant
mais il était tellement plus il a été un
des grands bâtisseurs du québec moderne
jeune souvenir de lui
d'abord comme ministre de l'économie et
des finances j'étais tellement
impressionné par sa connaissance de
l'économie du québec faisait qu'une
bonne partie de la politique économique
du québec a été pensé et conçu par oui
mais ce n'était pas seulement un homme
de conseils je les ai vus négocier des
ententes avec des entrepreneurs pour
faire aboutir concrètement des
investissements au québec
il a été un promoteur infatigable du
développement économique du québec
c'est lui qui a posé les fondations de
notre industrie numérique
il comprenait l'importance pour nos
entreprises de l'innovation
je suis aussi encourager une culture de
l'entrepreneuriat au québec et ses
ambitions dépassait largement les
frontières du québec
on doit pas oublier ses efforts de
promotion du commerce international
il combat qu'il a mené pour le libre
échange à la fin des années 80
sa passion pour le développement
économique du québec va toujours rester
pour moi une grande source d'inspiration
monsieur landry est un homme
profondément responsable
un homme capable de mettre en place des
programmes sociaux pour les plus démunis
mais capable aussi d'une grande rigueur
fiscale l'eau toujours d'ailleurs refusé
les étiquettes de droite ou de gauche
je me souviens aussi de bernard landry
comme de le premier ministre qui a
marqué l'histoire
il a négocié la paix des braves une
entente avec le peuple qui rident fondé
sur la confiance et le respect mutuel un
traité historique une première entre un
état et nation autochtone une
contribution exceptionnelle à la
paternité nos peuples
ce landry était aussi un orateur
exceptionnel qui avaient toutes un sens
de la répartie me rappelle des périodes
de questions lorsqu'on était au
gouvernement qu'une question s'adresse à
monsieur ans de vie on se regardait tous
constituait le position va en manger
toute seule mais derrière l'homme d'état
il y avait cet homme attachant même s'il
y avait un exemple par sa classe par son
irruption par sa grande curiosité
intellectuelle par son ouverture à tout
ce qui est humain il a élevé et enrichit
nos débats on va jamais assez souligner
sa générosité il disait le parti avant
les hommes et la patrie evans parti
sages conseils que je vais publier
monsieur landry donc les
accomplissements ce grand bazar du
québec n'ont pas fini de se faire sentir
son héritage va s'inscrire dans la durée
il va rester gravé dans nos mémoires de
sa maison sur les rives du saint laurent
il nous a inspirés jusqu'à la fin
cherchant talent merci d'avoir permis à
monsieur lambris passé ses derniers
moments à la maison je sais que tes
nuits ont été courtes au cours des
derniers mois merci chers membres de la
famille proche de bernard landry chaque
québécois
je vous offre au nom du gouvernement du
québec
mes plus sincères condoléances oui les
québécois forment quelque chose comme un
grand peuple et bernard landry aura été
à la hauteur de ce peuple qu'il a aimée
si passionnément
merci monsieur lendemain
[Applaudissements]